in his best-selling book 1421 British
historian Gavin Menzies argues that
Chinese ships reached the shores of the
Americas 70 years before Christopher
Columbus this history on book TV feature
runs 50 minutes today we are very happy
to present Gavin Menzies author of 14 21
the year China discovered America in
cooperation with a South Street Seaport
Museum when Margaret stocker our curator
read the review of 14 21 in New York
Times in January she immediately emailed
HarperCollins and lobbied for Gavin to
speak at india house which celebrates
the history of the clipper ship trade
between America and the Indies the 19th
century term for China Japan and
Southeast Asia Gavin Menzies was born in
1937 and lived in China for two years
before World War two he joined the Royal
Navy serving in submarines and following
in the wake of Columbus Diaz cabral and
Vasco da Gama
while in command of HMS Roarke while he
sailed the routes pioneered by Magellan
and Captain Cook since leaving the Royal
Navy he has returned to China and the
Far East many times and in the course of
researching 1421 he has visited 120
countries more than 900 museums and
libraries and every major seaport of the
late Middle Ages I am sure we will all
enjoy his presentation Gavin
Jorge Gregor president can you hear me
can you hear now can you hear now okay
can you hear over that side
george gregor president of this
wonderful india house and your spended
team governor Hertzog and margaret stock
are the curator thank you all very much
indeed for asking me today I can't think
of a more appropriate and beautiful
venue and I'm very honored to be asked
to come here I'd also like to thank my
publishers William Morrow imprint of
HarperCollins who've stuck their neck
out a very long way in publicizing such
a controversial book by a completely
unknown author and I particularly like
to thank Clare whack tell my editor
Suzanne Balaban who has arranged such
splendid publicity Jane Freeman and
Michael Morrison who have captained such
a splendid ship which seems at long last
to have reached port because just before
I set off to come here
we received the DNA results of the local
peoples amongst whom the Chinese settled
on their great voyage and I'm pleased to
say that 24 of the 25 who attested have
Chinese DNA
so my my my talk really is split into
four segments can you hear over that
side you can hear this the the first
part of the talk is that it was all an
accident
I planned nothing I had absolutely no
intention of overturning history I had
no intention whatsoever of showing that
Columbus was not the first person to
discover America it was a complete
accident the second part of the talk is
that
I discovered the most amazing fact again
by accident that not one of the great
European explorers who set off for the
new world discovered anything new they
all had charts which showed them where
they were going and the third part of
the talk is how I stumbled across the
fact again by accident that the people
who had charted the world who had
circumnavigate the world before the
Europeans were the Chinese and the
European explorers everything to them
and the final part of my talk is the
evidence which has come in in recent
weeks not least DNA which has arisen
largely because of the American public
who have sent me 16,000 emails in the
past four months
right so the last part of my talk yeah
okay do you want me to so the talks in
four parts the first part is that
everything was a complete accident I
didn't try and discover anything new
second part of the talk is how I found
that European explorers when they set
off all had maps showing them where they
were going they discovered nothing new
and the third part is how I found it was
the Chinese who first circumnavigated
the world and the final part is the
enormous help which I've had from the
American public since my book was
published in January we've had a hundred
and more than 190,000 people visited our
website in the last month which I've got
the figures and sixteen thousand of them
have sent emails with very useful and
important new evidence so a big big
thank you to the American public well it
all started by complete accident my wife
and I went to China to celebrate our
25th wedding anniversary and we arrived
on Chinese New Year's Eve in nineteen
1989 and it was a very beautiful evening
we stood on the Great Wall we saw the
really very harsh lands to the north and
the beautiful Chinese fertile lands to
the south and that evening we went to
the Forbidden City and because it was
Chinese New Year's Eve there were land
answers and Dragon processions and far
eat as no thoughts of exciting things
and at the end of the evening our guide
said to us well the most fascinating
thing about the this Forbidden City it
was that it was inaugurated on Chinese
New Year's Day 14:21 and the Emperor
sent a huge fleet of ships around the
world to collect the potentates of the
world's bring them to the Forbidden City
for its inauguration
and they were carried in sumptuous
luxury and they're provided with
wonderful food and concubines and
everything else and I thought this is a
very interesting fact that whilst in
1421 england was very poor country
struggling to make its way here was
China with an emperor who was rich and
powerful enough to send huge fleets
across the world so I decided to write a
book about the year 1421 in particular
what happened in China compared to with
what happened in England and England in
the same month February 14 21 that the
Forbidden City was inaugurated was also
hosting a very important event which was
the marriage of Henry the fifth the
great general and Catherine of Valois
the French princess by the marriage
Henry would unite France and England and
thereby end the Hundred Years War and
the country would be reborn well the
interesting thing to me was that at the
English celebrations after Catherine was
crowned in Westminster Abbey the guests
600 of them at a meal of salt cod which
was all the was was it was Lent and they
used stale bread for plates very very
simple celebrations in the same month
the inauguration of the Forbidden City
the Emperor entertained the rulers of
the world and 26,000 of his guests at a
twenty course banquet off the finest
porcelain and one of those plates was
auctioned by Christie's last year and it
reached the sum of eighty nine thousand
five hundred pounds so there was
absolutely yawning disparity between the
wealth and influence of China and the
wealth and influence of Britain in the
air 1421 so my book was to be about this
year and in particular this staggering
difference in political and economic and
military power to give another example
in June of 1421 Henry v landed his
pathetic little army in northern France
archers and he did it in fishing beds
and that same month half the world away
from China
the Emperor landed 28,000 men on the
east coast of Africa from Leviathan
ships and they had cavalry and water
ships to accompany the cavalry and an
array of far-far there was no comparison
whatsoever between China and European
powers at that time sir so I spent some
eight or nine years writing that book
and at the end of it my publisher said
well you must get it checked and I sent
book out in draft to be checked and one
of the professor's to whom I sent it
professor
Carolyn s of the University of
Minneapolis in Minnesota said did I know
of the famous Pitts igano chart which
our museum held the relevant the
relevance of this chart is that it
showed islands in the Caribbean and the
chart was published in 1424
so it was drawn up in 1421 so somebody
had been to the Caribbean 70 years
before Columbus set sail I worked on
this chart for about a year at the end
of that period I was able to tell
professor Carolyn s that I was
absolutely certain the islands shown on
that chart were Guadalupe II and Puerto
Rico and she agreed so I thought
wonderful I've got a fantastic ending to
my book I can show that the Portuguese
set sail on a secret voyage to the
Caribbean in the 1421 and they very
accurately charted guadeloupean Puerto
Rico and as a matter of courtesy I
thought I should tell the Portuguese
ambassador which I did and he was very
excited invited me to delightful and
boozy lunch and he introduced professor
Camilo de Santos there was a very
distinguished Portuguese historian
specializing in early Portuguese voyages
and he said well we must go together to
Lisbon to meet the keeper of the
National Archives to investigate in more
detail the secret Portuguese colony on
Puerto Rico so we went down to Lisbon
and they kindly lent me a professor to
help a person who could speak medieval
Portuguese and on the second day of our
investigations we found to our amazement
that far from the Portuguese having
discovered these islands they didn't
know anything about them at all
Prince Henry the Navigator sent to
caravels to discover these islands which
was shown on a master chart of the world
which the Portuguese Don Pedro had
brought back to Portugal in 1428 and the
Portuguese claims in their national
archives were that this master chart of
the world showed the entire world in
1428 it showed the Americas in
particular the Straits of Magellan which
was called the dragon's tail and it also
showed South Africa the Cape of Good
Hope which was called the Cape of
Bowness Francia and it showed the Indian
Ocean and the Far East so somebody had
not only charted islands in the
Caribbean which are shown on the pits
igano chart but they'd also charted the
entire world which was shown on the
portuguese master chart of the world and
of course this was a complete bombshell
it overturned everything that I was
writing in my book
and as it it sounds strange now but
sadly I decided I had to start all over
again and I did so at four years ago and
the first problem that I encountered was
that the 1428 master chart of the world
had disappeared from the Portuguese
archives about three hundred years ago
it's been lost nobody has seen it since
the mid 16th century although it has
been reported many many times in
from Portuguese journals and so on so my
first task was to see whether I could
verify whether in fact that chart
existed and whether there were other
charts which were derived from that one
which would show the whole world
discovered before the European set sail
and I started off with cartographic
mysteries were the charts of the
Americas which showed North and South
America before Europeans reached there
and were the charts of Africa which did
the same could we have the first slide
and I don't know if it's I don't if it's
going to be possible if you can't hear
with the mic I don't mind shouting can
you hear right and I'm sorry I can't
talk to people over there because the
layout of these mics I've got to talk
there so this this is the routes which
these Chinese fleet took now I just just
want you to think of that for the moment
I'm not going to describe the routes if
we could have the next slide
Oh would it be easier if I use the
remote control right okay now this this
is the crux of my argument this is how I
allege that every continent in the world
was charted before the European explorer
set sail and here at the center the
largest chart is current one as most of
us I think it'll recognize and the ones
around the edge are the old charts and
starting at the top left hand side is
the chart called the vault so Mulla that
shows the Pacific coast of North America
now if you go from the top left hand
side you can see the Pacific coast of
North America is etched in red and come
down to the center chart you see that
same bit of cased in red the next chart
the middle one is the Vinland map before
13:40 and what that map shows his
colored yellow and again it's reproduced
in yellow on the center chart the modern
one then the top right-hand chart is the
Cantino published in fifteen hundred and
two which shows the east coast of Africa
with longitudes correct two plus or
minus 30 miles long before Europeans
could calculate longitude of that
accuracy the bottom right hand chart
shows in the middle at the bottom the
north east coast of Australia in purple
and that's again reproduced on on that
centre chart so two years ago I came
absolutely convinced that what the
Portuguese claimed was true that the
whole world had been charted long before
European explorers set sail and I
thought well if this is the case then
the Europeans themselves who set sail
must have acknowledged that they had
seen or they possessed charts showing
them where they were going so I started
with Magellan because I know Patagonia
reasonably well and the bottom left-hand
chart which unfed you can't see very
well shows Patagonia and I knew that
somebody had been down there and been
down to the Antarctic four hundred years
before Europeans got there so I went to
Magellan stories and I looked up what he
had to say when he reached what we call
the Straits of Magellan Magellan just
before he got there he had a mutiny and
his sailors said we've been going long
enough we're starving were fed up with
his ratley's rat-infested biscuits we've
eaten all the rats there's nothing left
we want to go home Magellan told them
all to Don their formal clothes the
number one uniforms he mustered them on
the quarterdeck he donned his robots and
James donned his medals and James swore
the oath of sand James the most solemn
thing he could do and he told them
before we set sail I saw in the king of
Portugal's library a map which showed
the Straits through which we are now
passing I know it well if we continue on
we will reach the
and he said it in such a solemn and
striking way that his sailors believed
them and they agreed to go on and they
they did indeed reach the Pacific when
they crossed the Pacific Magellan showed
the chart of the Pacific to the king of
Limor Sava so Magellan was not the first
to go through the Straits of Magellan
now when I told this to various
reputable professional historians they
said well you've been captain yourself
you know jolly well if you're in a real
hole you'll flannel your way out of it
he just wanted to convince his sailors
that they should carry on of course he
didn't have it hadn't seen a chart
showing the Straits of Magellan so I
went back to the correspondence between
Magellan and the king of Spain and I
found that there was substantial
correspondence referring to the chart
which showed the Straits of Magellan
Magellan was cut in for 25% of the value
of the spices that he was going to bring
back once he'd gone through the Straits
of Magellan and he crossed the Pacific
he was very very worried that others
would use the same master chart to
follow him overtake him grab the spices
and pinch his profits so he wanted to
get a deal out of the king of Spain that
nobody else would be shown the chart
which showed the Straits of Magellan and
the king of Spain said well I'm sorry
I'll chat but I don't end the master
chart the king of Portugal does or words
to that effect so I can't help you and
therefore Magellan never got what he
wanted
the next person whose Diaries I went to
was Christopher Columbus and Columbus
too had an incipient mutiny when he was
22 days out from Spain on his first
voyage in 1492 he'd been a very very
brave captain Columbus he decided to
sail out with the wind which is a very
dangerous thing to do because if they
ran out of food or water sailing out
with the wind meant they had to turn
around to go home against the wind would
take them much longer and they they
might all die the normal practice before
Columbus was to sail out into the wind
and come back with it so after 22 days
his sailors said to him we've had enough
we're never going to get home we've been
sailing with the wind we've got to turn
around now Columbus did very much the
same as Magellan after him he summoned
his his men onto the quarterdeck and he
told them before we set sail I saw on
charts master charts of the world and
globes the islands for which we're now
looking and I can tell you we are within
two days sailing this is a paraphrase so
once again he persuaded his troops to
follow him and carry on I once more look
back at the correspondence between
Columbus and the king of Spain and he
was indeed provided with a chart showing
him the islands of Sint Antilia and
satanís he was provided with the chart
by a man called Tosca Nellie and Tosca
Nellie the same time as providing
Columbus for the chart raped the king of
Spain saying here the islands which I
suggest Columbus looks for and they are
well known to you so Columbus had a map
Magellan had a map I did the same with
the diaries of Cabral reaching Brazil he
had a map showing them the way to Brazil
Vasco de Gama did going round Cape of
Good Hope and cooked in Australia so the
lot of them all at maps now the question
is who drew them
I the work I'd had done for the previous
ten years enabled me to say who it
wasn't it certainly wasn't Europeans
because one way or another Europe was in
deep trouble the front France and
England had ranked that themselves and
northern Europe and the Hundred Years
War Venice the old Dojima sunny-go was
dying
Francesca Foscari was sitting in the
wings he's ready to change Italy from a
sea part or a land pyre the Arab world
was an absolute turmoil the Mameluke
Sultan's there were five in 12 month
period in 1421 and Tamburlaine lands
were wracked by civil war so by process
of elimination I found it must be China
but I had no proof so here comes the
proof I started off with this chart on
the left which is the cantina and as you
can see by comparing the cantina with a
modern chart of Africa the latitude the
longitudes of the east coast are
amazingly accurate over a seven thousand
kilometer piece of coastline there is a
20-mile era of longitude far far better
than anything the Europeans of that date
could achieve I knew that the Chinese
did have methods of calculating
longitude and so I wondered if it was
they who drawn the chart and I had my
next huge stroke of luck I remembered in
Venice my wife's Italian we go to Venice
quite often because it's near her family
home I remember in Venice seeing a chart
drawn by a man called from ara
and this chart showed South Africa well
drawn and he was published fifty years
before Europeans got to the South Africa
and it showed the Cape of Good Hope so
from our own you before Europeans got
there that South Africa had a triangular
tip and you could get from the Atlantic
to the Indian Ocean so was it the
Chinese well from our Oh came to my
rescue because on his map in the Indian
Ocean he showed huge Chinese junks and
they're very well drawn and he also said
I have obtained my information from a
European merchants who has substantial
experience of travelling in the East so
I went back to Venice find out who this
merchant was and I found it was a man
called Niccolo dark aunty who left
Venice in 1419 traveled over land to the
affray T's and he got down to mount the
malabar coast of India at Calicut by
extraordinary coincidence at the very
moment that this huge Chinese fleet
under the command of Zhang Han his
Admirals was coming through from China
to the Indian Ocean so they both arrived
in Calicut on the Malabar Coast at
exactly the same moment and de Conti
describes the Chinese junks there's no
doubt whatsoever that he was there
because he describes their triple
bulkheads that cross planking the water
containers they had with them and the
customs of the crew so I went to Niccolo
darkened his Diaries to see what he came
to have done and he he claims to have
traveled with the Chinese fleet from
India to China far Australia so I
thought well is that true can I find out
about it where should I go
well from our a once more came to my aid
because on his fifth 1459 chart drawn
long before Europeans got to the Cape of
Good Hope he said this in about year
1420 a or junk from India cross the
Indian Ocean non-stop past the Cape of
Good Hope sailed into the Atlantic for
forty days until they reached the Ellis
Firdous and from there they passed
through the ilis fathers for another
seventy days they reached the obscured
islands so I went to see we're assuming
for it was true we're a junk which had
left the Cape of Good Hope would have
reached after a forty days sail well
this map helped me this is map on the
left is the Kang nido it's a Chinese map
it shows the tips
Africa and it was published dates are in
dispute but it was after 1400 - and
before 1470 whatever the date is it was
long before Europeans got there so it
seemed to me that the Chinese had
actually got to the Cape before
Europeans now where would they have gone
in the forty days and where were they
Ellis Firdous sorry
wrong way it was really easy to
determine where they'd have got to
because these Chinese junks were very
curiously built they were huge 150
meters long they're also enormous ly
wide 50 meters wide and they had lug
sails and they had flat bottoms and the
combination of their enormous width and
their lug sails and their flat bottom
meant that for all practical purposes
they were constrained to sail before the
wind now and with the current on the
after you get to the Cape of Good Hope
there's a current which sweeps up the
west coast of Africa any ship off the
Cape of Good Hope if you just hoist the
sails and does nothing it'll get carried
up the west coast of Africa whereupon it
reaches the wind systems of the South
Atlantic which go all year round in a
big anti-clockwise oval so I knew that a
ship rounding Cape would been carried up
to the Bulge of Africa when the wind
would have started to carry it into the
central Atlantic and then it meets the
trades which push it back to the coast
and cut a long story short I was
absolutely certain that that junk in out
of speed of 4.8 knots which was the
average speed of the Chinese junks
fleets would have reached the Cape Verde
Islands and they would have approached
them from the Northeast and of course
the Cape Verde Islands have exactly the
same name
Ellis fared as as from arrow had said so
I thought if I'm right if I go to the
feast Island of the Cape third group
I'll find evidence of the Chinese voyage
their Chinese were very very proud of
their navigational skills and as they
went along on their voyages they erected
stones which they carved in the local
languages they're about ten of these
stones in the Indian Ocean carved in
Tamil and Persian and farsi Arabic etc
so I went to santo antão north east
islands of the Cape Verde Islands where
I found very very quickly near a stream
a large stone carved in inexplicable
writing and one which the first
Europeans found when they got to the
Cape Verde Islands in the 14 forties so
my next thing was to quest was to
translate the writing on this stone and
I couldn't work out who it was what
writing it was something I'd never seen
before so I decided to take good
photographs in the Morning Sun and send
them to the Bank of India because the
Bank of India and on their banknotes as
you probably know have about 15 or 20
languages of all sorts of curious
scripts and the Bank of India came back
and said well it looks to us like
Malayalam language I'd never heard of
and I said where is Malayalam and they
said it's the language of Calicut and
that was where the fleet sailed from so
prow Morrow was absolutely right a ship
or junk from India had sailed across the
Indian Ocean and round in the Cape of
Good Hope and 14 days later had reached
the Cape Verde Islands well that gave me
enormous confidence so the next thing I
decided to find out is where a
square-rigged flat bottomed junk would
have got to after leaving the Cape Verde
Islands and the once again it's very
very easy to find out because the winds
and tides would have blown the junk from
the Cape Verde Islands due west to the
Americas and just before you reach the
Caribbean the current
and winds diverge one lot of wind
carries you Northwest woods to the North
America and one lot of wind and current
carries you Southwest woods to South
America so I went once again back to the
charts I knew that the fleet must had no
choice but to have reached North America
and South America so I went back to the
charts to find out what parts of the
Americas was shown on charts before
Europeans got there and really ideally
we haven't got time we should go back to
the first chart I showed the vaults the
vaults a mullah which shows the Pacific
coast of North America I'm not going to
describe that now because I'm going to
deal with the East Coast chart which
shows Florida very clearly very well
drawn especially Cape Hatteras is the
Cantina which was published before any
Europeans reached that part so I was
absolutely sure in my mind that the
Chinese must have charted the coast of
Florida and they must have settled in
Florida in South America the piri Reis
and the Cantino have a beautiful
depiction of the not only the Amazon
Delta but the Amazon River itself 2,000
miles of its length so I was absolutely
sure that the Chinese must fleet must
have made landfall near Amazon Delta and
sailed up the river so I started my
search to find out evidence of the
Chinese making landfall and settling
settling in these places by now the end
of last year my book had come out in the
UK and it created quite a lot of
interest and a lot of information came
in particularly from people in North
America and South America who said they
knew of artifacts Chinese artifacts
which were hitherto inexplicable for
example
it was brought to my attention that up
the Amazon River where the Sala marsh
and the Negro River converge there are
the first Europeans to reach there found
all manner of Chinese plants and animals
they found water buffaloes which came
from Southeast Asia they found rice
which was brought from Southeast Asia
they found coconuts and bananas all of
which are completely foreign to South
America and they found Chinese chickens
and everyone finds it hilarious but a
large part of my research revolved
around Chinese chickens chickens as you
know can't fly and they can't swim and
Chinese chickens have wholly different
bodies they have different waffles [ __ ]
combs legs feathers size eggs calls
they're completely different to the
European breed and the first Europeans
who reached North and South America
found Chinese chickens
they also found Chinese rice Chinese
roses hibiscus Chinese ship dogs in the
places which I've shown there so my next
task was to go to the diaries of the
leading historians who charted the
Europeans reaching the Americas to see
what they described by now we are in
January February this year and I my book
was published in America and Suzanne
managed to get me on Diane Rehm Show and
other various bears some other
prestigious talks and information
absolutely bucketed in we've had
thousands and thousands of emails and in
particular I just want to show you three
things which after the die Diane Rehm
Show came to me which are shown on this
chart they're green triangles and on the
coast
of what is now Virginia the bottom of
those green triangles somebody emailed
me to say did I know about George
Washington and his friends when they
were draining the Great Dismal Swamp to
find more land create more land for
agriculture George Washington his chums
formed a company to drain the Great
Dismal Swamp and they succeeded in doing
so and then and when they had drained it
they found to their astonishment that
coming up through the mud was a Chinese
junk and of course they wondered how on
earth had got there and this was a
reading test for children in the
twenties and thirties in America they
always asked how can you explain the
Chinese junk which came out of the mud
in the Great Dismal Swamp and further up
the coast Giovanni da Verrazzano who was
the first European to reach what is now
New York he'd been sent there by the
King of France Francois premier to try
and find a Northwest Passage to the
Pacific and he raped his formal report
of proceedings when he got to what is
now New York saying that he met Chinese
people when he got there and then
further up in South West Greenland
another gentleman rate did I know about
the papers famous letter saying that a
fleet of barbarian huge barbarian ships
had arrived off of RC South West
Greenland in about the 1418 and they'd
carted away the poor inhabitants and set
fire to the churches and then return
them two years later and I might say
that fanciful though it seems the Pope
was quite right he should actually have
gone a bit further and said when the
women returned they were pregnant
because the DNA reports which we've just
got the people of for fal'cie have
Chinese DNA so close to Chinese and you
could say they are in fact Chinese now
the the gentleman who sent me the
account of Giovanni da Verrazzano sent
me off thinking
if I go to the accounts of the first
European explorers who reached the
Pacific coast of North America the
Pacific coast of South America
up the Amazon perronnette paraná and
Paraguay rivers up the Mississippi on
the East Coast North America everywhere
where I say that the Chinese settled if
I'm right the first Europeans who
reached those places should have found
Chinese people and they did everywhere
starting on the Pacific coast of North
America in what is now British Columbia
that are described it as colony
shinhwa's the people there the elutes of
Queen the Hyder people of Queen
Charlotte Island have once again DNA so
close to Chinese they could be Chinese
coming down the coast
the first Castilians to sail up the
pacific coast of america when they got
to oregon
they found Chinese junks fur Ella and
Cabrillo everything I'm telling you now
is in the bibliography on my website WWE
further down first European to be sent
to California to do an inventory of the
Californian people found major Steven
powers found between the Russian and
Sacramento rivers a Chinese colony
further down in Mexico Vasquez de
Coronado found not only Chinese people
when he got to what is now Phoenix
Arizona but he also found Chinese junks
and the Mississippi with gilded stones
going up the East Coast
the first Castilian viceroy of Florida
Pedro menéndez de avilés
found Chinese junks wrecked off Florida
and then further up again Captain John
Smith the Battle of the Fallen Timbers
1774 describes the people there who
claimed they were Chinese further north
Giovanni da Verrazzano met Chinese same
goes for South America everywhere that I
say through
massive other evidence that the Chinese
settled the first European explorers
found Chinese people and I say to have
done so it's unarguable it must follow
that the Chinese preceded Europeans to
the Americas thank you very much
Thank You mr. Menzies I think we have
some time for a few questions
follow me which there will be a book
signing by the author and the
opportunity to chat with him with the at
that table but let's do some Q&A first
before you ask you a question please
make sure you have the mic with you
I actually have I actually have two
questions if one assumes that there are
two questions the first one all right my
first question is if we are to assume
that the migration of approximately
30,000 years ago across the Bering
Strait were people from Asia Chinese
Mongolian wouldn't that provide for the
DNA that you're talking about and number
two how many how many vessels were in
this Armada that they could leave them
here and there all over the coast and
still have more vessels to continue or
did they build as they went the two
questions were first of all on DNA the
first people from China and Siberia
crossed the Bering Straits 30 thousand
years ago surely that would account for
the Chinese DNA that's the first
question and the second question is how
many ships were there did they build
ships as they went along how do you
account for so many people
correct so if I could answer the second
question first the number of ships I
grossly underestimated the number of
ships in my book I said a hundred ships
which is my best estimate after going
through what Chinese records I could
find
however professor James Finlay of
Arkansas University very kindly drew my
attention to the accounts of Vasco da
Gama
when he first reached Calicut 80 years
after the Chinese fleet had passed
through and he was told that 80 years
earlier that's about 14 28 I gained ting
fleet of eight hundred ships and burst
in in calico not 100 as I said in my
book 800 and the populations of the
fleet was so enormous that there was no
City
between China and India which had such a
population who's bigger than any city
they knew of the population so it was a
really massive endeavor the second
question which will recur time and again
when the DNA results are published is
surely you can account for the DNA in
the places where I say the Chinese
settled you could account for that by
being brought across the Bering Straits
when they were frozen the really
fascinating thing is that first of all
this DNA study if that was the case if
he didn't come across from Alaska then
the DNA the peoples of North America
would be gradually died the people who
came across the Bering Straits would be
perhaps gradually diluted as they passed
across North America and then went right
down into South America however however
this study shows that the people
thousands and thousands of miles apart
have the same DNA for example the people
of the Aleut Islands and the people of
South West Greenland and the certain of
the Maya people of the Yucatan Peninsula
and certain Inca peoples of South
America have have DNA which is so close
to Chinese you could say it was Chinese
yet the people living around them have
quite different DNA they have local
Indian DNA so that's the first point the
second point is that we have done some
very clever and eminent biologists and
specialists in tropical medicine are now
kindly helping me on research and for
example the people of the Amazon who
have Chinese DNA two and a half thousand
miles up the Amazon they also have
hookworm
and roundworm and these diseases cannot
be carried in coke in cold conditions
you cannot keep hookworms and round ones
alive in the Arctic they only can be
bred in hot moist conditions so those
same people with Chinese DNA also as I
say have hookworm and round well they
also have other diseases other otherwise
unique to Southeast Asia
Tokelau hepatitis B lack of duffy blood
groups and so on so you can link the DNA
of those peoples with not only that is
it Chinese but it's Seaborn
so my final point is that if it was
carried across the Bering Straits and
percolated down then the people the
Indian people living near the Bering
Straits would have DNA similar to
Chinese but they don't have quite
different
sir
we have a mic
I think all of this is very fascinating
better am I in it
very fascinating but what I wonder is
this is so why would the Chinese have
allowed the Europeans for five hundred
years to perpetuate the idea that they
were the people who found North America
it's a wonderful question thank you very
much the question was why would the
Chinese have perpetuated the idea if
they really did get the Americas first
allowed the Europeans to perpetuate the
the fairy story that Europeans
discovered America well what I didn't
say in my talk is that the emperor had
really rotten luck shortly after the
fleet sailed from Beijing in March 14 21
in May the most ghastly an extraordinary
storm hit Beijing and bolts of lightning
went straight down the middle of the
city along the path which only the
emperor was allowed to tread and as it
went down this path these belts of
lightning they destroyed one palace
after another all of the palaces were
turned into a very expensive carpet of
cinders and the Emperor thought it was
so violent and so significant that his
palaces were destroyed that he was no
longer the son of heaven he'd lost
confidence in the heavens had lost
confidence in him and he in effect
had a nervous breakdown and his son took
over his son was a devout Confucian and
Confucians as you well know dislike
trade with the long-nosed barbarians
they say over three seas trade is not
necessary that all that matters is that
the farmers of China are kept happy and
the true Confucian values are adhered to
everyone knows their place in society so
when his son in effect took over he
thought that the first thing he'd do was
to scrap these ridiculous
overseas voyages which were costing the
country huge sums of money
when the fleet got back the first slot
got back in 1422 and two more fleets got
back in 14:23 when they got back instead
of the hero's welcome they found that
the captains and crews were pensioned
off the ships were laid up the dry docks
in which they were built were flooded
all the blueprints for building new
ships were destroyed the animals they
brought with them were allowed to starve
and when Judy's grandson took over those
policies were intensified ending with
the burning in 1477 of all records of
the great voyages the outside world was
to be expunged from the minds of the
Chinese people and China steadily
descended into Senatobia and isolation
and stayed there for all their centuries
until Dan shoppings reforms before you
study this and do you have any idea what
was the reverse trade treaties don't
just send though their stuff because
they love the people at the other end of
the route somebody must have been going
back do you have any idea what was the
reverse trade on the Silk Route please
reverse trading on the Silk Route as
mainly the principal item most important
by a very very long way were horses the
Emperor imported millions and millions
of blood horses from Tajikistan and
Central Asia they had much better
qualities than any Chinese horse and he
needed millions and millions of them
duty so massive was his demand for
horses for his cavalry for his fleets
going overseas that he set up a special
horses for tea bureau and in return for
providing horses the people of the Silk
Road
had special access to Chinese tea which
into teas rain assumed greater economic
significance than either porcelain or
silk so that was by a mile the biggest
item Venetian glass was popular Indian
dancers and Persian women were very
popular and please be seated for just a
moment I'm going to invite governor
Fernandez to join us here we won't read
the proclamation but essentially the
Board of Governors of India House are
bestowing honorary membership to Gavin
Menzies for his contribution to the
cultural activities and the promotion of
learning seafaring as it may be and to
our art Lynch series so we thank you and
thank you again for joining us thank you
all for joining us the next step is to
join us at the signing table for those
of you interested in having an
autographed copy of what appears to be a
limited supply of a Gavin's book but
it's here so thank you
Gavin Menzies is author of 1421 the year
China discovered America it's published
by William Morrow an imprint of
HarperCollins visit HarperCollins calm
for more information next week on
history on book TV Empire Niall
Ferguson's exposition on British and
pure